Cory listen to me godamn it I was out in
the deep water again chasing Brown crab
and I found another
[Applause]
Darby this Darby had a prophecy tattooed
on his back every Thousand Years the
number one Darby has to meet up with the
number two uh Darby and transfer its
accumulated knowledge telepathically if
the two darbi's don't make the transfer
the oceans float into space bye-bye
Cincinnati
Derby I found is the number two Darby
and he needs our help to find the number
one Derby who has gone missing I'm just
a simple Brown crab hauler I cannot do
this alone come on core we saved the
world the last time we found a goddamn
Darby you want to save it
again you had me at Brown
crab okay all right okay that's that's
me again I'm in Darby 2 you were in
Derby one